الان سننتقل الى استوديو صباح العربيه في
باريس مع ليث بازاري بعد قليل سيكون معنا
ينضم
يستضيف هناك فرقه او ملوك الغجر من باريس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني مين ما بيعرف جيبسي كينج ملوك ودائما
فيها نوستالجيا من الموسيقى خصوصا للي
كانوا كتير يحبوا اغانيهم وحيقابلهم اليوم
الباريس مراسل صباح العربيه من هناك
مباشره ليث مزاري يسعد صباحك في عيد
العربيه العشرين اهل الليل يسعد صباحك
صباح الخير لكما بدي اقول كل 20 عام واكثر
ونحن جميعا بالف خير وشكرا لكم انتم امام
الشاشه في صباح العربيه شكرا على الاخلاص
والثقه ومعرفه الاكثر عبر عبر العربيه
يعني هنا باريس مدينه الانوار يا نادين
السهام والثقافه والفن وكذلك الموضه
والازياء ضيوفنا اليوم مميزون بكل مسارات
يليقون بعيد عشرين لقناه ميزت محتوى ما
تقدم وميزت بمشاهدين اوفياء معنى اليوم
شيبسي كينجز وتشيكو
صباح الخير تشيكو صباح الخير من الممتع ان
تكون معنا في العيد العشرين لقناه العربيه
وعيدكم الثلاثين ايضا
30 عاما على اغنيه منبوليا وانا
اتمنى عيد سعيد لقناه العربيه ولكل الذين
يشاهدون في العالم العربي
انتم هنا منذ 30 سنه
الديسكا البلاتيني هو الذي حصلتم عليه
وحصلتم على الديسك الذهبي وجائزه غرامي
وفي العام 2013 حصلتم على كثير من الجوائز
نحن على الهواء منذ عشرين سنه تقدمنا
كثيرا انتم كيف تتاقلمون ايضا مثل ما
تاقلمت العربيه
انا مؤسس
منذ العالم من العام 1900 العالم 1981
النجاح حتى عام
اتيت مع شيكو وسنكون قريبا في المنطقه في
بالمنطقه وانا سعيد جدا ان الموسيقى تتقدم
ونحن تتقدم ننتج المزيد من الاسطوانات
ونقوم بمزيد
المناطق نزول مدين من في العالم سنكون
قريبا في دبي
الى دبي مثلا عام 1979 ان الشرق الاوسط لم
يكن مثلما هو الان ذهبنا الى دبي ذهبنا
الى الشارقه ذهبنا الى مناطق اخرى في
الشرق الاوسط وكان لدينا جمهور في العالم
العربي شيكو قبل ان تغني كنتم كنتم انتم
زرتم السعوديه
بالتاكيد انا زرت
الرياض وكانت الزياره رائعه كان هناك طبعا
الاعمال واجتماعات متعلقه بمؤتمر ولكن هو
كان هناك الموسيقى
سنعود شيكو الان كيف تتاقلمون مع التغير
مع تغير العالم نعرف اغانيكم
كيف تاقلمونا موسيقاكم مع متطلبات الجيل
الجديد فالحياه تتغير والشباب يتغيرون
ماذا تفعلون
نحن محظوظون لان حياتنا المهنيه عالميه
ونتاثر بالتيارات في العالم اجمع هناك
اجيال كامله تستمل تستمع الى موسيقانا
ونحن نتاقلم بعد اسابيع قليله سنصدر
البوما جديدا مع شركه يونيفرسال نغير بعض
الشيء الاصوات لدينا نغير التوجهات
الموسيقيه ندخل بعض الموسيقى من جنوب
امريكا ونحن نحن محظوظون لانه معنا في
الفرقه الفرقه موسيقيين من العالم اجمع
ونحن عجائب جدا الان سنترككم لتغنوا
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
شكرا جزيلا لك
يعني شو هالجمال وهالطرب احنا رجعنا هيك
بسنين حلوه واكيد كل الناس اللي عم بتابع
هلا صباح العربيه وتابعوا مقابله ليث
بازاري مع جبسي كتير استمتعوا بهذه
الاغاني الرائعه ليث كمان احنا بنحب نشكرك
نشكر جهودك لانه انت عنصر اساسي في قناه
العربيه طوال هذه السنين من اول من ضمينا
احنا للعربيه واحنا بنشوف تقارير ليث اللي
هي مميزه جدا بلشت بتقارير السفر والترحال
واستكشاف البلاد وايضا انت جزء اساسي في
صباح العربيه من خلال تقاريرك شكرا جزيلا
لك ليث من هنا الى باريس شكرا